WE HAVE LIGHT, AND THE VISUAL
SPECTRUM GOES FROM RED TO BLUE,
JUST LIKE A RAINBOW.
BUT OUTSIDE OF THAT,
THERE'S LIGHT THAT WE CAN'T SEE,
AND ON THE BLUE SIDE,
THAT'S CALLED ULTRAVIOLET.
Narrator: U.V. LIGHT
CAN BE CREATED ARTIFICIALLY
AND HAS MANY USES, FROM
STERILIZING HOSPITAL EQUIPMENT
TO GROWING INDOOR PLANTS
TO AFFECTING SKIN COLOR.
THERE ARE TWO KINDS OF
U.V. LIGHT -- UVA AND UVB.
NOW, UVA IS A LONGER WAVELENGTH.
IT CAN PENETRATE DEEPER,
AND IT'S THE U.V. RAYS
THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE IMMEDIATE TAN THAT YOU GET.
UVB LIGHT GIVES YOU VITAMIN D,
WHICH IS GOOD FOR YOUR HEALTH
BUT CAN ALSO CAUSE SKIN CANCER
DOWN THE LINE.
U.V. LIGHT DAMAGES
THE SKIN CELLS
BY BASICALLY DESTROYING THE DNA.
WHEN YOU TAN,
WHEN YOUR SKIN CELLS ARE EXPOSED
TO ULTRAVIOLET RADIATION,
THE DAMAGE TRIGGERS THE RELEASE
OF MELANIN.
MELANIN IS THE DARK PIGMENT
THAT CAUSES TAN.